สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิงแล้วก็
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนเดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะคะ
[เพลง]
วันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีครับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 28 ครับเดือนอะไร
คะเดือนกรกฎาคมครับ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิด
ตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่ครูนิคอยู่เวลา
8 โมง 28 นาทีครับ
ตอนเช้านะ
888 เลยนะคะ
ฟังไม่ค่อยดีเนาะ 888 จริงๆดีนะคุณนิคชอบ
เลข 8 เพราะว่าแต่ฟังแล้ว
คุณพูดถึงเวลาตด
ท้องเข้าห้องน้ำ
น้องเรียนกำลังกินข้าวอยู่นี่อิ่มเลยนะ
ครับเหมือนที่คุณหญิงอยู่เนี่ยนะคะก็ 9:00
น
ค่ะตอนเช้าเหมือนกันแต่ว่าเร็วกว่าของครู
นิค 1 ชั่วโมงนะคะ
วันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงจะมีเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็มีคนที่ทำงานบนเครื่องบินแล้วก็ผู้โดย
สารทั้งเกือบไม่ได้ทั้งหมดเกือบทั้งหมด
เนี่ยนะคะก็เสียชีวิตแต่ว่ามีผู้โดยสาร
อยู่ 3 คนที่ไม่เสียชีวิต
เครื่องบินตกลงไปในน้ำใช่ไหมคะอ่าเราก็
อาจจะสลบแล้วทีนี้มันก็น้ำทะเลเนี่ยมันก็
มีคลื่น
ก็พัด 3 คนนี้ค่ะเข้ามาที่เกาะร้างเกาะ
หนึ่ง
เกาะร้างก็คือเป็นเกาะที่มันไม่มีคนใช่
ไหม
อาจจะมีคนแต่ว่ามันอยู่ไกลมากหรือเปล่า
ใช่ค่ะก็ใช่ๆก็คืออาจจะอาจจะไม่มีคนก็ได้
คือคือแบบเนี่ยเป็นเกาะอย่างเงี้ยไม่มี
บ้านคนเห็นไม่มีโรงแรมแล้วก็ไม่มีเรือที่
ที่จะพาเราไปไหนมาไหนได้อ่ะหรือว่ากลับ
เข้าฝั่งได้เนาะก็เป็นเกาะร้างนะคะแต่นี่
สวยนะคะเกาะล้างเนี่ยถ้าอยู่เกาะร้างแบบ
นี้ก็โอเคนะแต่ปกติมันจะไม่สวยขนาดนี้นะ
คะปกติพอเวลาเราได้ยินว่าเกาะร้างเนี่ย
มันฟังดูแล้วเหมือนมันมีผีอ่ะมันจะต้องมี
อะไรอ่ะ
นะก็นั่นแหละค่ะก็มาถึงซักตัวเหมือนกับ
โดนคลื่นซัดขึ้นมานะคะพอพอสักพักนึงแต่ละ
คนเนี่ยพอตื่นขึ้นมาเหมือนกับว่าเอออาจจะ
นอนอยู่ตรงเนี้ยสักพักนึงแล้วนะคะอ่าก็
แบบมองออกไปที่ทะเล
ก็เห็นว่าอู้มีซากเครื่องบินอยู่
แล้วก็ดูร่างกายของตัวเองว่าเจ็บตรงไหน
ไหมตรงไหนหักตรงไหนไม่โอเคหรือเปล่าซึ่ง 3
คนก็ปลอดภัยดีอาจจะมีแผลอะไรแบบนิดหน่อย
นะคะเราก็เรียก 3 คนว่า A  B  C แล้วกัน
จะได้ง่ายๆ
ก็ ABC เนี่ยนะคะก็ติดมาในเกาะเนาะเขาก็
เดินนะเราเรียกว่าเดินรอบๆเกาะ
ก็เดินดูว่ามีบ้านคนหรือเปล่ามีอะไรไหม
หรือว่าอาจจะเจอคนอื่นใช่ไหมจากเครื่อง
บินลำเดียวกันที่อาจจะอยู่อีกฝั่งนึงของ
เกาะหรือเปล่านะคะแต่ก็ไม่เจอใครเลย
แต่เจออันนี้ค่ะครูฟ้า
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าเช้ามากนะ
ก็เรียกก็เรียกผิดเหมือนกันที่เคยเรียก
ผู้หญิงเป็นครูเอ๋
พอกันนะเราสองคนก็ยกเว้นใช่ก็ C นะมี ABC
ใช่ไหม C เนี่ยนะคะเขาก็คืออาจจะเดินแยก
กันเนอะซีเนี่ยเขาก็เจอเข้ากับอันนี้ค่ะ
เราเรียกว่าเป็นกล่องเหล็กอ่ะกล่องนึง
เดี๋ยวคุยให้ดูรูปแต่นี้มันอาจจะเป็นรูป
รูปวาดนะคะ
เขาก็เจอกับกล่องใช่ไหมเนี่ยกล่องอันนี้
พอเปิดกล่องมานะคะก็เจอกับน้ำเปล่า 1 ขวด
ครับส่วนอีก 1 อันเนี่ยที่เป็นเหมือน
แกลลอน
มันก็อาจจะเป็นพวกเหมือนสารเคมีอ่ะค่ะว่า
เห็นๆลูกนี้เนาะหัวกะโหลกไขว้เนี่ยนะ
ใช่ถ้าเปิดออกก็จะกลิ่นของมันก็อาจจะทำ
ให้เราไม่สบายดื่มเข้าดื่มก็ไม่ได้นะคะ
พวกนี้สารเคมี
แล้วก็ไม่เจออะไรเลยนะคะไม่เจออะไร 3 คน
เนี่ยสีก็เก็บของมาแล้วก็พอมาเจอกับ a
กับ B เนี่ยก็เล่าให้ฟังว่าเออๆเราไปเจอ
อะไรบ้าง
แล้วแบบในเกาะร้างอย่างนี้มันมีแต่น้ำ
ทะเลใช่ไหมมันก็ดื่มมันก็กินไม่ได้นะคะ
แต่ว่าซีเนี่ยเขามีน้ำเปล่าอยู่ 1 ขวด
ที่เขาเจอแต่เขาบอกว่ามันเป็นของเขาเขา
ไม่ให้ใครทั้งนั้น
แล้วเขาก็เอามันก็จะมีอีกถังนึงใช่ไหมถัง
แกลลอนที่เป็นเคมีอ่ะค่ะเขาก็แบบว่าน้ำ
เปล่าอันนี้ของฉันนะเอาไปสิก็โยนแกลลอน
ที่เป็นเคมีอ่ะค่ะให้กับ a ให้กับ a และ b
a กับ B ก็รู้สึกแบบ
โกรธ
ซีมากๆแบบทำไมไม่รู้จักแบ่งให้กันแล้วยัง
มาโยนถังให้แบบหิวน้ำก็กินอันนี้ไปสิ
2 คนก็โกรธมากๆนะคะพอถึงเวลากลางคืน
ตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยนะคะด้วยความโกรธเนี่ย
เวลามันเป็นตอนดึกๆอ่ะก็น่าจะประมาณซัก 4
ทุ่ม 5 ทุ่มแล้วกัน
เขาก็แอบแอบเดินเข้าไป
ตรงที่ที่ 4 เนี่ยนอนอยู่
แล้วก็เจอกับขวดน้ำเป็นขวดน้ำเนี่ยขวดน้ำ
a เก็บเอาไว้ใช่ไหมใช่ขวดน้ำสะอาดเลยนะ
ดื่มได้เลยนะคะน้ำเปล่าเนี่ยนะคะ a เนี่ย
นะคะก็เอาขวดน้ำเนี่ยเอาสารเคมีเนี่ยเท
ใส่ลงไปในขวดน้ำ
[เพลง]
คิดว่าถ้ากิน
เหมือนกันนะคะ
เขาเหมือนจะมีคล้ายๆเป็นแบบแท่งเหล็กแหลม
อ่ะค่ะเหมือนเป็นแบบนั้น
จะเป็นหลอดใช่ไหมแต่ว่ามันเป็นหลอดเหล็ก
คนเล่นกอล์ฟแต่เป็นมันเป็นเหล็กก็เลยอัน
นี้เป็นเหล็กแหลมๆใช่ค่ะคือเป็นเหล็กแหลม
ๆที่แบบอาจจะเป็นแบบส่วนหนึ่งของเครื่อง
บินที่มันตกอ่ะค่ะที่แบบเออ B เขาเจอมา
ใช่ไหมคะเขาก็แบบว่าเอาแท่งเหล็กอันนี้
สมมติเป็นแก้วน้ำนะสมมตินะคะผู้หญิงไม่
ได้เอาขวดน้ำมาก็เอาแท่งเหล็กเนี่ยเจาะ
อันนี้ก็ได้เจาะที่ก้นขวด
ก็คือสมมุติอันนี้เป็นแท่งเหล็กใช่ไหม
แล้วก็
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ให้น้ำเนี่ยมันรั่วออกให้หมด
C จะได้ไม่มีน้ำดื่ม
แล้วเขาก็บอกว่าแล้วอันนี้นะแล้วความ
ต้องการของเอกของกับ B ก็โอเคก็เหมือนกับ
เย้ได้ดังที่คิดนะคะเพราะว่าสุดท้ายแล้ว C
เนี่ยก็ตายเพราะขาดน้ำสะอาด
เพราะว่าขาดน้ำ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละแล้วเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย 2 คนก็
เดินไปแล้วก็ไปเจอกับเหมือนกับเป็นแหล่ง
น้ำจืดที่มันดื่มได้กินได้นะคะ
ใช่แต่สองคนก็ไม่รู้ว่าทำไมซีตายใครฆ่า 4
นั่นแหละก็ทั้ง a และก็ B ก็เป็นคนที่น่า
สงสัยใช่ไหมคะเพราะทั้งเกาะมันมีกันอยู่ 3
คนน่ะ
ซีตาย
แล้วนะคะฟังแล้วครูนิคเนี่ยคิดว่าใครที่
ทำให้ C ตั้งนี่
จริงๆเนี่ยถ้าฟังจากเรื่องที่คุยพูด
คิดว่า
ครูนิกต้องอธิบายก่อนเพราะว่า
a เนี่ยเขาเอาสารเคมีเนี่ยที่อันตรายใส่
ไปในน้ำใช่ไหมครับแต่ว่า B เนี่ยเขามี
เหล็กที่เจาะใต้ขวดน้ำเพื่อให้น้ำมันไหล
ออกมา
แล้ว
เขาสองคนก็
จริงๆแล้วเขาสองคนก็คง
[เพลง]
เพราะเขาสองคนก็คิดว่าที่เขาทำเนี่ย
สำเร็จ
เพราะว่าฟรีก็ตาย
แต่แค่เขาไม่รู้ว่าจริงๆแล้วคือใครที่ทำ
ให้ตาย
[เพลง]
คนที่ฆ่าเนี่ยคือ B ทำไมคะทำไมครูนี้ถึง
คิดว่าเป็น b ก็คือคนที่เจาะใช่ไหมให้คน
ที่เอาเหล็กเนี่ย
เพราะว่า
ผู้หญิงบอกว่าซีตายเพราะว่าขาดน้ำสะอาด
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะแล้วคุณคิดว่าถ้า B เนี่ยเขา
เอาเหล็กแหลมมาเจาะใต้ขวดหลังจาก a ก็แปล
ว่าน้ำที่มันมีสารเคมีมันก็ต้องไหลออกไป
ด้วย
แล้ว
ซีอาจจะตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วเจอว่าขวดมันไม่มี
น้ำ
เขาก็กินน้ำดื่มน้ำไม่ได้
คิดว่า
ดีน่าจะเป็นคนฆ่า 4 ค่ะคุณหนิงบอกใช่ไหม
ใช่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ถูกต้องหรือเปล่า
ถูกต้องค่ะ
มันมันเป็นเหมือน
คือภาษาอังกฤษเขาจะเรียกว่า
ผู้หญิง
ช่างมันนะคะมันเป็นเรื่องราวคืออันนี้คำ
ถามที่ผู้หญิงเอามาถามคุณนี่แหละค่ะมัน
เป็นสิ่งที่ผู้ใช้หนึ่งคนที่เป็นคน
อเมริกาเนี่ยเขาเขียนเอาไว้เขาชื่อ
มิสเตอร์ซาโมเลี่ยนเขาเรียกว่าซามูเลี่ยน
Paradox
ใช่
คือมันเป็นแบบตั้งแต่ปี 1976 อ่ะค่ะเขา
บอกว่า
คือเราต้องคือบางคนแหละอาจจะคิดว่าอ๋อ
C เนี่ยต้องตายเพราะสารเคมีแน่ๆเลยเพราะ
เราจะรู้สึกว่าสารเคมีเนี่ยกินแล้วมันทำ
ให้ตายใช่ไหมคะแต่จริงๆแล้วมันเหมือนที่
คุณนิคบอกเพราะว่า
C ตายเพราะว่าไม่มีน้ำดื่ม
เราก็ต้องมองว่าแล้วทำไม C ถึงตายสาเหตุ
ที่ซี่ตายมันไม่มีน้ำดื่ม
แล้วใครที่ทำให้ C ไม่มีน้ำดื่มมันก็ต้อง
มองแบบนั้นแต่บางครั้งเนี่ยเขาก็บอกว่า
คือคนเนี่ยก็อาจจะมองจากสิ่งที่อยู่รอบๆ
หรือมองจากสิ่งที่เราคิดว่า
สารเคมีมันอันตราย
C ต้องตายเพราะสารเคมีแน่ๆเลย
ก็จะคิดอย่างนี้ไปก่อน
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะคุณซาโมเลี่ยนเนี่ยเขาก็
บอกว่าถึงแม้ว่าบีจะเข้าไปก่อน
ก่อน a นะอ่า B จะเข้าไปเจาะที่ก้นขวด
เสร็จแล้ว a เอาสารเคมีลงมาใส่ยังไงสิก็
ตายเพราะว่าไม่มีน้ำดื่ม
ดีก็เป็นคนข้ามเหมือนกัน
จริงๆแล้วตอนแรกเนี่ยครูนิก็คิดว่าอาจจะ
เป็น a แค่เพราะว่าถึง
ถึงแม้ว่า B เนี่ยเขาเจาะขวดน้ำใช่ไหม
ครับน้ำมันไหลออกเนี่ยมันอาจจะไหลออกช้า
ก็ได้แล้วถ้า C เขาตื่นมากลางดึกมันยังมี
น้ำนิดหน่อยแล้วเขากินโดยที่ไม่รู้ว่ามี
สารเคมีเขาก็ตายได้เหมือนกันคือ
แต่
คือถ้าโอกาสคนที่มันจะฆ่าเขาได้สูงกว่า
เนี่ยก็คือต้องเป็นดีแหละ
ใช่เพราะว่าเราก็บอกใช่ไหมว่าเขาตายจาก
การที่ขาดน้ำสะอาดเพราะว่าไม่มีน้ำสะอาด
ให้ดื่มเขาก็เลยแบบว่าเวลาที่เราเล่า
เรื่องนี้หรือว่าเล่นเกมนี้ใช่ไหมคะเรา
ต้องฟังดีๆเหมือนกันนะเออเหมือนเวลาที่
เราฟังอะไรอ่ะเราก็ต้องฟังดีๆเพราะว่าบาง
คนอาจจะฟังแล้วก็คิดอ๋อสารเคมีกับไม่มี
น้ำบางคนอาจจะมองว่าการที่สารเคมีมันทำ
ให้ตายได้แน่นอน
เพราะว่าเราไม่ได้มองว่าอันนี้เขาอยู่ที่
เกาะล้านนะ
เกาะร้างเนี่ยไม่มีน้ำเนี่ยทำให้เราตาย
[เพลง]
คนนี้ก็คิดว่าเพราะ a เนี่ยเขาใส่สายเคมี
เข้าไปใช่ไหมแต่มันเป็นสารเคมีที่ผสมกัน
น้ำอ่ะ
มันก็จะไม่ได้อันตรายมาก
จำนวนนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยผสมกับน้ำเพราะคุณ
นี้ก็เคยแต่อย่าทำนะนักเรียนคือคุณนิก็
ไม่ได้ตั้งใจเพราะว่าคือทำกับตัวเองด้วย
คือมันเกิดจากคุณนี้ก็ล้างจานแล้วมันก็มี
เหมือนถึงจะแก้วน้ำที่คุณนี้การล้าง
เหมือนไม่ได้ล้างสะอาดอ่ะแต่เราลืมไงคือ
มันก็จะมีน้ำยาล้างจานอยู่ในแก้วนิดนึง
แล้วคุณก็บอกหิวน้ำคุณนิดก็เลยเอาเนี่ย
น้ำเทลงไปแล้วก็กินรสชาติเป็นยังไงคะคุณ
นิดมันก็มันเป็นน้ำยาล้างจานสูตรมะนาวมัน
ก็จะดีกับคอนะวันนี้เจ็บคอคันคออยู่ใช่
ไหม
แต่ก็ไม่ได้ป่วยไม่ได้อะไรนะเพราะว่าไม่
ถ้ารู้สึกแปลกๆแต่มันไม่สบายตัวมันฟุ้ง
เลยว่ามันไม่ใช่น้ำแต่มันก็จะไม่ได้มี
อันตรายไม่ได้เป็นอันตรายกับเรามากที่ทำ
ให้เราตายค่ะใช่หรือว่าแบบว่าจริงๆอ่ะถ้า
B เขาไม่ได้เจาะเอาน้ำออกใช่ไหมคะแล้ว a
เนี่ย C ขอโทษค่ะซีเนาะคนที่ตายเนี่ยนะคะ
เขาคิดอยากจะดื่มน้ำอ่ะถ้าในน้ำมันมีสาร
เคมีบางครั้งเวลาเราเปิดขวดอ่ะมันก็ยังจะ
แบบได้กลิ่นหรือเปล่าเออหรือว่าดื่มนิด
หน่อยรสชาติมันแปลกๆ
มันก็จริงๆก็ใช่นะเพราะว่าพอเวลาถ้าเป็น
คนน้ำเนี่ยแล้วมันปิดฝาเอาไว้อ่ะมันอะไร
ที่มันอยู่ในนี้นานๆนะพอเปิดอ่ะมันเหมือน
กับกลิ่นมันก็อัดอยู่ในนั้น
ออกมา
ก็เลยเขาก็เลยบอกว่าเป็นเหมือนกับเวลามัน
อาจจะเป็นสิ่งที่เรามาเล่นเกมกันว่าเออ
ใครเป็นคนฆ่าแต่ว่าด้วยความแบบหลักการ
หรือว่าสิ่งที่คุณซาโมเลี่ยนเนี่ยเขาคิด
ใช่ไหมคะด้วยความที่เขาเป็นนักเหมือนนัก
คณิตศาสตร์อ่ะไม่รู้เรื่องอะไรอ่ะ
เหมือนเรียนเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขอ่ะค่ะแล้วก็
แบบเก่งเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขนั่นแหละเขาก็เลย
แบบเขาจะคิดใช่ไหมว่าเออคนเนี่ยชอบมองใน
มุมนี้ก่อนนะอ่าแต่จริงๆแล้วเราเวลาเรา
เจออะไรเราเห็นอะไรหรือว่าเราฟังอะไร
เนี่ยเราต้องฟังแล้วก็มองให้ครบทั้งหมด
ต้องฟังดีๆ
นั่นแหละค่ะก็เป็นเรื่องเกมเอามาเล่นกับ
ครูนิกนะคะคุณนี่เก่งมากเลยผู้หญิงเล่น
เกมกับใครทุกคนเก่งมากเลยอ่ะ
โบว์ฟ้าหมวกฟ้าก็เกาะบ้างเหมือนคุณนิคนะ
คะ
แต่ก็แกเป็นเกมที่สนุกเพราะว่าคุณมิกซ์
อ่ะชอบเล่นเกม
จะชอบเล่นเกมพวกเมื่อก่อนคนที่จะชอบดู
โคนันเหมือนกัน
แล้วก็จะชอบดูหนังที่มันมีเกี่ยวกับฆ่าคน
แล้วครับไอเป็นคนฆ่าเป็นฆาตกร
เพราะว่าอย่างที่คุณนิดบอกใช่ไหมว่าดีก็
คือฆาตกรก็คือคนที่ฆ่า 4
นั่นแหละค่ะก็เป็นเกมสนุกๆเนอะแต่ว่าวัน
นี้เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วนะคะโอเคไว้เราเจอกัน
ใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ